with a coronavirus vaccine on the way
president trump is expected to sign an
executive order today that will make
sure all americans receive the vaccine
first before the united states begins
helping other countries
here to react is fox news medical
contributor and author of that great
book right there
make america healthy again dr nicole
sapphire hey dr sapphire
good morning good morning so how will
this work
so the president is expected to sign an
executive order today which really just
falls in line with his america first
initiative that he's been pushing all
along
there's an international collaboration
going on right now called kovacs meaning
trying to
make sure that the low and middle income
countries will have access to the
to the vaccine the president is saying
that he wants to make sure that of all
the vaccines that the united states has
purchased
that americans will be offered the
vaccines first before they start
distributing it internationally
the good news is under operation warp
speed the president has already
purchased over 200 percent the supply
needed for americans
so there will be excess so he wants to
make sure that any american who wants
the vaccine
can have it before they start working
with the international bodies to make
sure that the low and
middle income countries also have access
to those vaccines okay dr sapphire uh
regarding the fda meeting it's in two
days it's on thursday
you know many every single day more and
more people are dying do you feel like
they were dragging their feet should
they have
talked about this and approved pfizer a
few weeks ago
that's a good question question there
are some people in the community right
now that
do believe that members of the fda are
dragging their feet they are scheduled
on thursday
to review the eu way for pfizer we still
don't know exactly
when they will give us an answer whether
it'll be thursday whether it'll be
friday
um you know we're looking forward to the
meeting on thursday but yes could they
have potentially
met sooner possibly but they've been
reviewing the data and
been allowed for public commentary all
which are very important in this process
thanks dr sapphire